we are going to move on we're taking
calls at 6 1 7 830 4750 let's take our
next caller caller what is your name and
also let me know where you're calling
from let's start their name and count
it's Grady from Dallas Grady Grady is
arguably the biggest football fan in the
audience of the david pakman show you've
never called him right Grady I've never
called it no I have not are you ready
for the super bowl I am so ready for the
super bowl I am rooting I would assume
you're rooting for the Patriots that's
correct I'm rooting for Atlanta why
because they're like my second team
after Dallas but I mean I don't know I
kind of like the underdog okay I got if
you're not from the New England area you
would you would support the underdog
because I mean the Patriots just keep
winning year after year it seems okay
all right well what was I don't know you
weren't calling to talk about football
Grady so I'll let you get to your
question okay well okay so I want to
talk to you about how you manage your
time David with when you're like outside
of work do you work or do you like when
you first got started I assume you like
hustled a lot to get your show like
going right like how do you manage your
time now I mean I try to have some kind
of delineation like I do i do a lot of
work at my desk at home and so it's very
hard I've got kind of like do any eight
this is work time and this is not worth
time but I really do try to just manage
the time in a way where I'm saying I'm
no longer working from now on and
because the constant sort of blurring of
when work is happening and when work
isn't happening I don't find
particularly good and so yeah I try to
say ok that's it I'm done with work for
the day and if I see like an urgent
email or text message pop up I'll deal
with it or if I'm notified that like our
website is crashed but for the most part
I try to say like ok I'm going to work
on x y&z for the next two hours and then
like that's it and I'm going to do
something completely different
okay all right cool cool oh but are you
having as everything how's this show I
just want to say okay I just want to say
your show is so important and like I
will say I wouldn't have found out
anything about like I just you know
independent media like yourself is so
important David because I've really
gotten back into listening your show
like constantly daily and like I just
say it is important I thank you thank
you finding a lot of people out the
election really reengaged with the
independent media of all kinds yeah the
show all right Grady well listen um I
would say good luck to the Falcons but I
wouldn't mean it so I won't even pretend
you know all right best of luck I want
it to be a good game alright thanks so
much always great to hear from Grady in
Texas I think probably the biggest
football fan in the audience that's a
big statement but well it's huge in the
united states football is big football
is absolutely big i see it's possible
that your friend is on hold i'm not
going to pick them up today or maybe
just someone from the same area codes i
have no idea but at any rate won't do it
let's take another caller key